Well,
we're to human rights come from,
you know,
here you can say where do they write so
the comatose come from or the babies
come from.
It's the fact that within us we have a
sense of moral purpose and we know
innately most of us,
whether something seems right or seems
wrong and we have the rules that we live
our lives by which they do not do such
and such to some individual,
it may hurt to not be disrespectful and
I think that that has to extend beyond
those we relate to most because the true
test of compassion is if you can be
decent to those,
you relate to least.
So I believe it comes from within us
from where we get kindness generally and
where we're able to be altruistic to
others.
That's where it.
We should extend that.
Yeah.